we will now talk about expectation
maximization a very general machine
learning approach in bioinformatics that
is applied to a wide range of
bioinformatics problem for example one
of the most popular motif finding
algorithms in bioinformatics is an
expectation maximization algorithm
please note that there is one question
that remain unaddressed for both coin
flipping and k-means clustering in coin
flipping we have not discussed yet what
to do if the probability of
sequence being generated by the blue
coin is exactly the same as the
probability of the sequence being
generated by the green coin
and likewise in k-means clustering we
have not discussed how to assign a
midpoint to
two clusters that this point is
equidistant to
and in hard assignments we have no
choice but to make a decision either
blue or red in this case but in soft
assignment we saw that there is yet
another possibility to
assign fifty percent of point to blue
cluster and 50
to red cluster but how do we assign
these responsibilities
let's
uh recall how we derive hidden vector
from the previous uh lecture
let's say in this case let's assume
parameters are
0.60 for the blue coin and 0.82 for the
green coin which coin is more likely to
have generated the first sequence with
these four hats
in this case we simply computed the
probability of sequence being generated
by blue coin
sequence being generated by green coin
compare them turn out
that the blue coin is more likely and
that's how we constructed the hidden
vector
but now
let's try to be a little bit more
accurate instead of deciding blue
or
green let's compute the responsibility
of blue and green coin for the first
sequence of
flips what are the responsibilities of
coin for this segment
well probability of this sequence being
generated by the blue coin is 0.00531
but probability of it being generated by
the green coin is much smaller
so it makes sense to assign
responsibility
of the blue coin as probability of the
blue coin divided by sum of
probabilities of blue and green coins
and likewise probably responsibility of
the green coin will be equal to
probability of the green coin divided by
sum of probabilities of green coins and
blue coin as a result we derive that
responsibility of the blue coin for the
first
series of coin tosses is 0.97 and the
responsibility of the green coin
correspondingly is 0.03
so that's we are starting to build the
hidden matrix
what is the responsibility of the second
sequence once again we compute
probability of the second second
sequence being generated by the blue
coin and the green coin and similarly
compute the corresponding
responsibilities proceeding in this way
we compute the entire hidden matrix
so expectation maximization algorithm
works in the following way
we start from data and whatever random
choice of parameter and perform the e
step
of the
expectation maximization algorithm which
from compute from data and parameters
compute the hidden matrix
now what we would like to do is
given hidden matrix
and data we would like to compute
parameters and it is still unclear
how we can do this and that's where what
we learn about the dot product will help
us
let's recall how we use the dot product
to compute
parameters remember that
the bias of the
blue coin was estimated as the dot
product of data
and hidden vector while the bias of the
green coin was estimated using the dot
product of data and one minus hidden
vector
now let's talk
take a look at the hidden vector and
let's ask the question
how is the hidden matrix corresponding
to this hidden vector would look like
this is a simple question because
the first row of this matrix will simply
be
exactly the hidden vector while the
second row of this matrix will be 1
minus hidden vector
so after we figure it out it means that
since the first row of the hidden matrix
is the hidden vector we can rewrite the
expression for the bias of the blue coin
as
data
dot product with
the first row of the hidden matrix
and we can rewrite the bias of the green
coin as the dot product of data and the
second row of hidden matrix divided by
the corresponding
expression on the right of course
and now after we figure out how to
compute
biases of coins through hidden matrix
we can compute the whole the entire
hidden matrix is shown here
and we now accomplish this task
transforming hidden moving from hidden
matrix and data to parameters
and
we
currently i showed you how to do this
for the simple hidden matrix based on
a binary vector derived from the hidden
vector but whatever
are the rows of the hidden matrix we can
use the same formulas that shown in the
boxes in the slide and in this case the
parameters will be the one shown on this
slide for the blue coin 0.48 and for the
green coin
0.81
the only question left to address before
we move to soft cayman clustering is
what to do in our coin flipping
experiment if there were k coins for
example three rather than two coins
if you
watch how i was deriving
parameters
using dot products then you will see
the parameters which represent k-mer
vector can be computed simply as a
product of an n-vector n-mer vector data
by the k
times and hidden matrix and this simple
elegant formula will help us to move
covert soft k-means clustering in the
next segment
you